i am on time
all the time
and i don't care
happy hump day america
so do i have a great monologue tonight
huh the best one of the year i think
eh what's the hurry
you got to be somewhere
sandra
i love the new i love the new place yeah
whatever
that's so white of you
a bunch of racists
oh look at you i'm important time is
money i have places to see people to
meet wonder bread and mayonnaise to eat
you typical bigot always in a rush
thank you
it's true
urgency is racism
at least according to the oregon health
officials who delayed a meeting for no
other reason than stating that urgency
is a white supremacy value
as excuses go it sounds a lot better
than the dog ate my alarm clock
but it raises a key question since my
show starts on time every night do i
qualify as a grand wizard
in an email obtained by the great
magazine reason regional health equity
coalition program manager danielle
droppers great name told folks that a
scheduled conversation would not take
place as planned because urgency is a
white supremacy value that can get in
the way of more intentional and
thoughtful work
which i assume is what she calls
sleeping in and then watching the view
from her toilet
oh my god that's how i watch it
so what a happy coincidence for a
government worker
that it's racist to do your job
whether it's holding a scheduled meeting
or teaching children math doing both is
racist so don't bother that way everyone
fails not just government now this is
the oregon health authority an actual
agency tasked with coordinating medical
care as well as unloading covet info
during the pandemic
so it's no wonder they screwed up that
state over covid it would have been
racist not to
and could you use a broader brush to
paint with blacks are never in a hurry
so when usain bolt outruns a white guy
which is every time is that reverse
racism
hey usain what's the hurry slow down
you're starting to run like a white guy
[Laughter]
you know i worry i wonder if this stuff
will ever show up at fox
yeah i had a great time at the lake
house this weekend dan i didn't know you
could fit that many hot dogs up there
oh my god we gotta help him quick what
are you doing don't you know that
rushing is a major tenant of white
supremacy and your shallow desire for
fast results can stop people from
joining your cause either because
they're late or they don't work here
how could you be so insensitive
you know you're absolutely right deb
thank you for educating us
[Music]
i promise to do the work
let's go
[Music]
now
to educate the confused on why urgency
is racist another employee pointed to a
white anti-racist educator who pushes
the idea that harmless traits are
actually evil proof of white supremacy
stuff like wanting to write stuff down
or being a perfectionist it's getting to
the point where i don't understand when
they use the term white supremacy do
they mean it as an insult or a
compliment
so you write stuff down you seem to
value time and you want things done
right i mean you just described the
perfect employee and all the things that
made this country the envy of the rest
of the world now apparently this is all
part of diversity inclusion and equity
training materials d-i-e for short
which is what any company that promotes
this crap will do
but you know what this is good news for
lazy and competent workers
[Laughter]
he's asleep right now
show up late
unprepared stinking of booze
you're fighting white supremacy now
looking back on it in college i was a
regular rosa parks
i got to admit this is pretty diabolical
i mean what a great way to ruin
someone's career tell them all the
things that make you successful also
make you a bigot it's like a boxing
trainer telling his protege hey if you
want to be a world champ someday don't
go to the gym don't worry about your
footwork and smoking will actually
improve your lung capacity oh and for
god's sake don't avoid mcdonald's that
is delicious
by telling others that good traits are
racist you're telling them to fail cnn
must have had this plan in place for the
last 10 years
but you couldn't ask for a better way to
leapfrog past inept gullible co-workers
plagued by white guilt you get them all
to stay home until they're tardy and you
win by showing up on time all while
telling minorities don't reach your
potential oh you'll get equity once
everybody loses of course for those
bureaucrats who aren't held accountable
like miss droppers their incompetence is
expected hell public health bureaucrats
can literally cause a pandemic and still
not get fired the only thing they do on
time of course is collect taxes
so here's some questions for miss
droppers whose name is perfect for
someone dropping standards for herself
if urgency is a racist value why don't
we delay your paycheck
for like a few weeks
gonna make us all a little less racist
and how about your summer vacation is it
cool we just get around to that in the
fall the beach is still nice in november
don't even think about leaving friday
early to beat the traffic you're no
better than robert byrd forget sunscreen
and just put on your white hood
and think about you know obama and
harris in jackson they're all historical
firsts
how very white of them to come in first
you best hope you don't end up in the
emergency room anytime soon i mean can
there be anything more racist than an
emergency emergencies demand quick
action
nurse i need 200 cc of atropine stat
i mean whenever you get around to it
sorry didn't mean to sound like a bigot
seriously imagine being a doctor trying
to curb your urgency
son you need an appendectomy asap or
your appendix could burst and you could
die omg did i just say asap what am i a
doctor or a plantation boss at any rate
i'm hitting the links we can catch up
tomorrow unless you're dead
yeah dead
death talk about finally escaping your
own racism and really we'd all rather be
dead than called racist and the fact is
isn't death really the least racist
thing ever think about it what do they
call you when you die
[Applause]
this former track star never jumps a gun
when bringing a story co-anchor of
america reports sandra smith
he's like mr clean muscular bald and
leaves a lemony scent
former acting attorney general matt
whitaker
that's funny
she's smart attractive and inspiration
to young women everywhere
wait who wrote this
fox's contributor cat tip
and finally his paper airplanes must
submit a flight plan my massive sidekick
in the nwa world television champion
tyrus
you know sandra welcome to the show
thank you i i'm all i'm almost
speechless though because this new set
greg congratulations it is it is awesome
yeah when you asked if we had a live
audience we should have just said no
exactly because they're just amazing
well i'm glad you came late to this
party uh it makes you the least racist
person here i was late actually you were
actually late to the show you are
adamant about not being late so i i i by
my by this definition i am the most
racist person that ever watched i am
like i am i i am
always trying to beat the previous
record on the show of getting out like
that's the whole thing i called it i
screwed it all up you did you did
because you had to change your clothes
sorry about that what you didn't pay
[Laughter]
it's another example of wasting taxpayer
funds i mean these are literally
government employees
getting paid on taxpayer dime
who are late and they decide to have an
excuse a lame excuse that but the irony
of all of this is in this moment of all
the perils in the current white house
administration guess what democrats are
screaming
they want to see more urgency from the
biden administration i mean i couldn't
help but see
that insane irony in this moment that's
what governor pritzker in illinois is
saying about president biden we want
this president to be more urgent step up
to the plate bold action
so that was my one simple observation
but yet another example of wasted
taxpayer money yeah he i mean there are
times when he's very urgent but it's
usually
involving a bowel movement
oh my gosh
you could have seen that coming like a
frisbee in the desert
it's coming right at you here it comes
so matt you're white
yes yes
that's all i have out of the way
i just want to thank you for coming you
know what greg life is urgent let's
remember that yes because you
hurry
to get things done to succeed
basically you're taught from a childhood
all of the you know qualities that make
successful people and then ultimately
you fight not to die yes and get
everything done before you die and so to
me
this is just the one thing you can say
that allows people never to argue back
is that that's white supremacy i mean
because if you argue that against this
woman then you lose that argument 100 of
the time do you think that there she was
just hungover
i mean this is the i only make excuses
when i'm hungover
uh so i what does that say about me you
have a lot of excuses
yeah we already know that nobody can get
food poisoning that often
but you see what i eat when i'm drunk
what do you think think that this was
real i i don't i i think this was a this
is kind of the cat ate my homework
on steroids yeah i mean that that's
that's this this is impossible that
someone actually believes that the
quality of urgency
is a white supremacist value yeah and is
this a person that's an expert on that
now i mean let's what are the yeah i
would love to have her write more emails
and more excuses as to why she can't
meet with
tax paying voters yes because you're
racist kat did you ever eat your
homework
no no that's good yeah good for you you
know it's kind of it's kind of sad
because it feels like this is a white
supremacist movement
taking these traits and making them
sound racist when they're actually could
be
put to good use yeah i was really
confused by this one so i started
reading more about it and then i got
even more confused
because uh the explanation was basically
you know when you're in a rush then you
can't
you know stop and you know have like
good decision making which i agree with
like when i'm in a rush sometimes i'll
like forget my wallet or something like
that but i don't understand where the
racist part comes in yeah like being in
a rush you don't just like suddenly
start saying racial slurs at least i
don't is there a way to steal man this
argument like maybe just take like
you're saying like maybe taking your
time maybe it's about taking your time
it's not about rushing i don't know i
don't know where this is no i mean i
think it's like
bad things can happen when you're in a
rush again i read so much about it i
could not find anywhere where the racism
comes in
tyrus last word to you i was glad that
she finally brought it up um you know
i've been dealing with your racism for
six years
be on time know the topic
don't leave during the segment
i prefer to show up at like the fourth
at the end just say goodbye
get some applause and this white
supremacist has been holding me down and
forcing me to be on time so
i mean the bravery for her to come
forward and finally
fight for all us minorities to
say what needed to be said because we
can't be on time we we can't be smart we
can't have morals we gotta lower the bar
so low
so we can be equal with y'all and thank
you so much for stepping off your
high horse and helping us
is the most racist woman
ever she basically said
urgency being prepared knowing your
stuff
they can't do that yeah
this isn't like live news in the middle
of that you guys have like a delay where
you get the bleep button yes or can you
just drop cuz thank you for watching use
it say something
oh fair game i'm doing the best i can
i'm a minority
[Applause]
[Laughter]
they're so scared to talk
[Applause]
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else